حسنًا ، محطة الفضاء الدولية
ستتقاعد في عام 2031. تقول ناسا إنها تخطط
لإعادة مختبر الفضاء
إلى الأرض عن طريق اه الاصطدام به في
جزء بعيد من المحيط الهادئ
يطلق عليه النقطة نيمو ،
فما الذي يمكن أن نتوقع أن نتعلمه منه
قبل هذا  تنتهي المهمة بشكل جيد القائد
كريس هادفيلد معنا
رائد فضاء متقاعد القائد السابق
لمحطة الفضاء الدولية ، من الجيد
جدًا عودتك إلينا ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك ، كان
علي أن أشير إلى
أنه بالطبع مؤلف
قائد جرائم أبولو ، شكرًا لك
استمعت كثيرًا إلى
الإصدار
عندما نتحدث عن عام 2031 وهو
يصطدم بالمحيط الهادئ ، وينتظر بعض الناس
دقيقة
كيف سيبدو ذلك
وكيف يمكن الاعتماد عليه وأقول ذلك
لأننا نعلم أن هناك
تاريخًا لبعض  إعادة الدخول غير المنضبط هنا
skylab على سبيل المثال أول
محطة فضائية أمريكية أه دخلت الغلاف الجوي للأرض
مرة أخرى في عام 1979. وأجزاء منها ضربت
أستراليا إذا كنت أتذكر بشكل صحيح ،
فتحدث معي
عن
ثقتك في
هذا الاتجاه الصحيح ،
هذا هو بيت القصيد كريستي
ولهذا السبب تتحدث ناسا عن
ذلك بالفعل الآن أعتقد أنه سواء كان ذلك في
حياتك الشخصية أو عندما
تطلق سفن فضائية ، فأنت بحاجة إلى
خطة نهاية الحياة واه  بالنسبة لمحطة الفضاء ميب
التي كانت المحطة الروسية
قبل هذه المحطة ، قادوها
إلى نفس الجزء من جنوب المحيط الهادئ
ولكن مع سكايلاب أول محطة فضاء أمريكية
، التي ذكرتها ، لم تكن
هناك خطة نهاية العمر
ولم يكن المكوك '  نحن على استعداد لإعادته ،
لذا فقد تم حرقه بشكل عشوائي
ومن ثم يمكن أن يصطدم بأي مكان على
الأرض ، لذلك نحن حريصون حقًا مع
محطة الفضاء الدولية ، أعني
أن أول قطعة تم إطلاقها في عام 98
كان لدينا مختبر كبير تم إطلاقه  لقد
كانت جيدة في العام الماضي لمدة
ثماني أو تسع سنوات أخرى على الأقل ، لكنك في النهاية
تريد خطة جيدة وهذا
ما سنفعله لأنني أفهم أن الغالبية
العظمى منها ستحرق
عند إعادة الدخول ، هذا صحيح.
معظم الناس يعرفون أنهم لا
يعرفون أن الأرض تصطدم بحوالي 40 طنًا
من الصخور كل يوم من النيازك تضرب
في العالم 40 طنًا يوميًا
وتحترق جميعًا في غلافنا الجوي ، وبالتالي
ستكون محطة الفضاء مثل واحدة من
أكثرها  سوف يحرق فقط ويتحول
إلى هذا الغبار الناعم الذي تراه
ينزل في شعاع الشمس ،
لذا يمكننا أن ننظر إلى نيزك
كان يعرف
ولكن سؤالي هو أن هذا يقودنا
إلى شيء كنا نتحدث إليه بالفعل مع
جانيت لبلاب حول هذا  الأسبوع الماضي
الحطام الفضائي الموجود أعني أن هناك
بعض القلق الحقيقي
أه من مخاطر وتهديدات
أه الأقمار الصناعية ورواد الفضاء
الذين يصعدون إلى الفضاء في هذه المرحلة
بسبب ذلك ما هو قلقك
وماذا تفعل  أعتقد أنه أكبر تهديد
من هذا الحطام الفضائي في الوقت الحالي ،
تخيل جيدًا أثناء قيادتي
لمحطة الفضاء الدولية ، وإذا
انتظرت بهدوء ، يمكنك سماع أجزاء صغيرة
من الأشياء ترتد من الهيكل ، لذا
يجب علينا
التفكير في الفضاء د  ebris ونحتاج إلى
تنظيم جيد بحيث يكون لدى أي شخص
يطلق شيئًا ما في الفضاء
خطة دورة حياة كاملة له وطريقة
لإفساده في نهاية حياته
ولم نقم بذلك جيدًا حتى الآن
ولكنه حقًا  الوقت المناسب للبدء في
القيام بذلك ، نحن بحاجة إلى تنظيم أفضل
خاصة وأن تكلفة الإطلاق قد أصبحت
أرخص كثيرًا مع
ما تفعله شركة Spacex ، مما
يسهل الوصول إلى هناك ، وهذا يعني
أننا بحاجة إلى تنظيم أفضل يهتم
بكل ما هو موجود هناك  وماذا
سيحدث عندما
يصلون إلى نهاية حياتهم المفيدة بشكل صحيح ،
لذا فإن مسؤوليتهم هي
تنظيف الفضاء بشكل
أساسي هذه مشكلة كبيرة في
الواقع الآن كريستي هي
مثل مسؤولية
تنظيف المحيطات
التي تعرفها
من الصعب جعل شخص ما مسؤولاً عن الأرضية المشتركة على الأرض أو المياه المشتركة ، لذا
عليك معالجتها بطريقتين ، لكن
أحدهما لا يُسمح لأي دولة
بالانطلاق إلا إذا كانت لديها خطة  لذلك يجب على
أي شخص يصدر ترخيصًا أن
يُظهر أن لديه خطة ولكن
عملية التنظيف الفعلية أشارك بالفعل
مع عدد قليل من الشركات والعمليات في
الوقت الحالي لمحاولة التوصل إلى
أذكى طريقة يمكننا مثلها تمامًا مثل
تنظيف القمامة  على الأرض لمحاولة القيام بذلك بأكبر قدر ممكن من
الكفاءة مع المشكلة التي
نواجهها في نفس الوقت لا نجعل
المشكلة أسوأ في المستقبل كما
سنفعل مع المحطة الفضائية في
ثماني أو تسع سنوات أو كلما
تقاعدنا فعليًا  نعم ، إن 2031
ليس صعبًا كما أفهمه ولكنه
حقيقي سريعًا قبل
أن أتركك ، لقد قام الإصدار للتو بعمل رائع
ما هو البديل
إذن لأنه شيء من هذا القبيل
لا يزال بحاجة إليه بالتأكيد
ما هو حقًا  رائع كريستي منذ
أه تعلم أنني ساعدت في بناء المحطة
منذ 20 عامًا وأمرتها قبل 10
سنوات ، أصبحت تكلفة الإطلاق
رخيصة جدًا لدرجة أنه أصبح الآن أه
قابلاً للتطبيق
تجاريًا للشركات التجارية الخاصة لطرحها
محطات ace للبحث من أجل أه مثل
بناء الأشياء والسياحة
وهذا ما تقوم وكالة ناسا بتسليم
المدار الأرضي إليه وهناك ما لا يقل عن أربع
محطات فضائية مختلفة في
مراحل مبكرة من التمويل الآن على
الجانب التجاري والتي سيتم تحريرها
بقية الكون ليذهب ناسا لاستكشافه